the justice department uh supports and
defends the first amendment right of
parents to complain as vociferously as
they wish i can't imagine any
circumstance in which the patriot act
would be used in the circumstances of
parents complaining about their children
nor can i imagine a circumstance where
they would be labeled as domestic
terrorism
didn't you just wish that guy was on the
supreme court well
new whistleblower documents reveal that
one day before attorney general merrick
garland denied targeting concerned
parents
the fbi was secretly planning to do just
that now on october 20th the fbi's
criminal encounter terror division
issued a memo asking agents to use
a so-called threat tag
to track investigations and assessments
of threats specifically directed against
school board administrators and other
school personnel in other words they're
spying on parents who question or
criticize the dictates of far-left
educrats
well what's truly shocking well we
probably would never have known
any of this if an unnamed whistleblower
hadn't come out spoken out reached out
to republicans on the house oversight
committee joining me now
is the committee's ranking member ohio
congressman jim jordan
now congressman did the uh a.g
what was he telling the truth
to congress or would you be willing to
believe
he really didn't know what was being
planned by his own justice department at
the time well he either lied to us or he
doesn't know either thing either either
one is bad for the country bad for
justice in america understand this laura
as we speak at this moment the fbi is
not maybe is treating parents as
terrorist threats and the attorney
general came in from the committee and
said just the opposite you just played
the clip he said i cannot imagine any
circumstance where we treat parents or
we give them the label of domestic
terrorists but in fact the day before as
you pointed out the day before an email
gets sent out to agents across this
country saying just the opposite say spy
on parents give them this threat tag
categorize label parents when i first
read this memo i thought this is no
different than what the irs did just a
few years ago when they had the remember
the bolo list be on the lookout for
these kind of organizations using these
kind of words and they had a list of
american citizens just like the fbi is
doing now so he either didn't know which
is terrible or he misled the committee
when he came in front of us and we need
to have him back plain and simple
well what he said though is
we're not
criminalizing or accusing people who
disagree that's a
constitutional
right to disagree we would not do that
this is about actual threats of violence
and to that you say
well remember how this all started we
got to understand the timeline september
29th a left-wing political organization
asked the president of the united states
to get the fbi uh involved in local
school board matters five days later the
attorney general general does just that
on october 20th we have this email that
goes out to across the nation about this
threat tag and then october 21st he
comes in front of the committee and
tells us all this october 22nd the
organization that started it all
apologizes for their memo and
withdrawals excuse me for their letter
and withdrawals their letter but yet
merrick garland we've asked him will you
rescind the memo will you stop this what
you've put in place what you've put into
action he will not rescind it he will
not withdraw he will not stop it that's
the that's the part that concerns me and
we have sent now countless letters we
have talked to we've fluttered to the
fbi to back to merrick garland to the
school board association to the uh
education all these entities we've sent
letters we need answers because it sure
looks like i think without a doubt this
is happening they are targeting moms and
dads across this country for simply
speaking out and saying we don't want
this racist hate america curriculum
taught to our kids imagine that
well
congressman it seems to me that with the
midterms coming up and by the looks of
it it's going to be a
republican wipeout of the democrats
they see that this issue is a potent one
and do you agree that the goal here is
to intimidate parents against showing up
and getting involved across the country
so this is like wildfire it's catching
on
they don't want it to happen
they're trying to chill chill first
amendment free speech this is all about
intimidating parents but one thing i
know one thing you know laura you're not
going to intimidate moms and dads no no
high paid lobbyists no bureaucrat ever
beats a mom on a mission the moms are
fired up and here's here's the great
thing courage is contagious we saw it in
virginia one mom stands up one dad
stands up pretty soon it's a whole
community and they're saying not with my
kids that is what is so wrong about this
and you're exactly right the idea that
this guy merrick garland was the
smartest man on the planet had to be on
the supreme court is such a crock and
the p and the american people see we saw
him testifying from our committee three
weeks ago he didn't even know there was
a press release that accompanied his
memo on october 4th and that press
release talked about getting the
national security division the
counterterrorism division involved in
this effort that is frightening he
didn't even know it or if he did know it
and misled us that's even more wrong so
he better come back in front of our
committee and be willing to answer some
tough questions about this and he should
stop this process right now
do you think the biden white house
is putting undue influence on the
justice department here for political
reasons that's a
serious charge because sackey today said
that's not happening it's independent
they're independent they're totally
different from trump that's what her big
point was today
of course they are we now have we now
have press reports that the white house
talked with the school board association
before the initial september 29th letter
was ever sent we know that when
president biden goes out and criticizes
the pro-life law in texas eight days
later the justice department brings suit
we know that when president biden went
out and criticized the georgia election
law changes a few weeks later what
happened the department of justice the
garland justice department goes out and
brings suit and we know what happened
here a letter on the 29th that the white
house coordinated with a left-wing
political organization five days later
they do exactly what this left-wing
political organization asks for and we
find out now they're treating parents as
domestic uh terrorists when in fact the
attorney general told us just the
opposite of course they're political
anyone with half a brain can see that
yeah what is it called a terror tag or
something like that i mean it's just
it's called a threat but you're right
it's a terrorist attack that's right
it's a terrorist tag that's exactly it's
called a threat tag but in in point of
fact is a domestic terrorist tag is what
they're putting on moms and dads for
goodness sake
congressman thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else